le gouvernement du québec lance un
nouveau service pour les chercheurs
d'emploi et les employeurs qui ont
besoin de main d'oeuvre le site québec
emploie utilise l'intelligence
artificielle pour faciliter la recherche
le service est gratuit et disponible dès
maintenant avec nous pour en parler jean
boulet le ministre du travail de
l'emploi et de la solidarité sociale
bonsoir monsieur goulet
bonsoir ce trio en quoi c'est différent
ce nouveau site de celui qui existe déjà
bah écoutez c'est un site qui s'appuie
totalement vous le mentionnez son
intelligence artificielle il ya des
fonctions de géolocalisation qui permet
un arrimage tout à fait compatible avec
ce que recherche le chercheur d'emploi
est ce qu'au besoin l'entreprise nokia
d'éloignement donc par secteur
d'activité par régions la personne qui
cherche un emploi au décret son profil
l'emploi y incarne besoin mais d'un nous
dit par exemple j'ai besoin d' avait
qualifié qui quart d'entre eux d'aider
dit que les doctrines yvonne massenet et
les personnes qui ont ce profil là pour
un déjeuner en compte entre externe à
l'image qui est vraiment efficace qui
s'appuient encore une fois ce qui
n'existe pas déjà dans le fond monsieur
boulet est ce qu'on n'a pas déjà toutes
sortes de structures pour permettre aux
gens de se trouver un emploi et aux
permettre aux employeurs de trouver des
employés
si le cycle plus moderne qui répond
quand même nous mentionne monde u20
technologie qui est parfaitement
efficace la géolocalisation c'est
vraiment spécifique et c'est un site qui
est spécialisé pour répondre à nos
besoins de main d'oeuvre dans cette
période de rareté qui est
particulièrement importante dans des
secteurs d'activités conab et où il ya
un besoin de ça est-ce que ça va régler
le problème des pénuries de main
d'oeuvre mais moi c'est fini voilà ce
qui me préoccupe là c'est qu'il ya des
chômeurs par des béquilles à des
personnes dont ils reçoivent des
prestations d'assurance
emploi il ya des personnes qui reçoivent
la paix certain succès d'anna pc je
pense qu'en s'inscrivant sur un site
comme soft qui va permettre un arrimage
rapide et complet dans la région selon
tes intentions des ambitions il ya même
deux raisons parce que quand on reçoit
des prestations
évidemment une fois indisponible faut
répondre à des offres raisonnables
d'emploi pour continuer de recevoir les
prestations
donc cela il faut qu'ils soient
efficaces rapides et mange maintenant
des résultats lors qu'ils vont être
assez intéressant le progrès à tous les
commerces et toutes les entreprises ont
des besoins
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de ça
présentement 94% des entreprises font
face à un enjeu de main d'oeuvre et 43%
des emprunts entrepreneurs estiment que
le québec doit accueillir davantage
d'immigrants est ce que les efforts ne
devrait pas être mis sur des solutions
comme ça c'est à dire d'accueillir
davantage d'immigrants pour répondre aux
besoins de main d'oeuvre ainsi une des
options et en même temps et impasses
ville de travailleurs québécois
disparaît qui est assez impressionnant
les gens vous le savez ni un emploi ni
aux étudiants en formation
il ya un potentiel intéressant d'un
jeune qui sont au chômage
les travailleurs expérimentés les
personnes élégantes les personnes qui
d'ailleurs ont des certificats de
sélection du québec vous pouvoir aller
sur ce seul à qui je souhaite sera le
plus performant des qui sera ouvert à
toutes les clientèles de bender et les
employeurs qui ont besoin de personnel
tablette temps partiel terme
puis les personnes qui travaillent des
étudiants aussi pour des emplois d'été
les personnes immigrantes
c'est une option mais aussi un potentiel
ici au québec est quand même assez
intéressant mais monsieur legault dit
que d'accueillir des immigrants sur des
postes à moins de 56 1000 par année ça
aggrave le problème de richesse du
québec êtes d'accord avec ce monsieur
voulait pas ce qui est important c'est
que il faut contribuer à l'amélioration
du salaire moyen au québec réduire
l'écart entre québec et l'ontario qui
nous sépare aussi nommément de l' ocde
il faut apprendre le pib par habitant
améliorer notre productivité cantons
seront pas parfois on considère qu'on a
des efforts considérables à faire pour
s'automatiser ceux numérisés seront
rebaptisés sûr pour moi c'est un intérêt
fondamental en même temps les dasri des
grands pour répondre à des besoins
notamment il emploie qualifiant d' or
énormément dans beaucoup de secteurs des
technologies de l'information
la santé l'enseignement pour la
construction ou des personnes
immigrantes ont le profil pour répondre
à nos besoins convention mais 150 mille
postes vacants ce moment la majorité ce
sont des bottes des postes en bas 205
ans de 56 1000 $ par année en bas du
salaire moyen
les employeurs le conseil du patronat
les milieux d'affaires les entreprises
vous dites on peut pas enlever du coffre
à outils les immigrants parce qu'ils
gagnent pas 50 email ou parce que les
postes sont en bas de 56000 est-ce que
c'est pas une vraie solution pour aider
à réduire la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
qui ralentit et l'économie du québec
quand vient de lancer mais se finir oui
c'est un des actions pigier parfois des
articles qui dément qu'un coup de
personnes immigrantes sont surqualifiés
pour les emplois qu'ils occupent au
québec
il faut les aider
les compétences acquises à l'étranger
qui est aigri notre marché de l'emploi
pourrait demain des secteurs qui sont
particulièrement névralgique à notre
économie
pis pour les on s'emploie on veut pas
non plus en faire totalement abstraction
je sais dans le monde manufacturier par
exemple des besoins importants pour être
béat
il faut aussi on veut à contre salaire
moyen au québec se concentrer d'abord et
avant tout sur ces emplois là qui m'ont
aidé à enrichir le québec
collectivement mais je répète l'homme la
majorité la grande majorité des emplois
disponibles postes vacants sont en bois
de 56000 ça va pas améliorer salaire
moyen du québec mais faut trouver des
solutions pour ces postes là et quand et
quand on regarde les chômeurs votre
collègue monsieur fait gribben disait on
peut prendre un chômeur ailleurs pour
aller combler les postes vacants il ya
deux ou trois cent mille chômeurs en
même temps la très grande majorité des
chômeurs sont denses et des secteurs qui
sont à l'arrêt notamment la restauration
oui absolument qui vous avez vu
d'ailleurs on a mis en place un
programme de formation et de
requalification d'un vendeur et ça
interpelle les personnes qui sont dans
tous les secteurs d'activités aussi
parfois indépendamment du niveau de
rémunération est dans le secteur
manufacturier notamment ya beaucoup de
jeunes de femmes de personnes il est
grand aussi participent à des parcours
de qualification soit des formations de
courte durée ou en alternance travail
études
on a besoin de tout le potentiel mais
pour répondre à nos problématiques de
paix de wendel bien ne sut boulet merci
beaucoup merci entre françois fillon
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i see her dit